all right so imagine this you're
creating a new startup smartphone
company your goal of course is to make
it huge right so you make your first
phone you launch with a bang you've got
a bunch of enthusiasts on board and
you're slowly starting to grow this
thing and it starts going well in Europe
and in India and a few other Asian
markets and you know things are starting
to grow and and go quite nicely but you
notice there's not a lot of pickup in
the United States for some reason now
there's a few reasons why this might I
mean a lot of people already know
there's a surprisingly high amount of
people who just walk into a carrier
store to buy their phones in the US so
if you don't have a deal with a carrier
then things might not go well for you
there and this is an Enthusiast only
thing they're selling them online so
that's understandable but then you get
to the stats and the stats say the
iPhone has somewhere around 50% market
share in the US Which is higher than the
global average and it is studly growing
every single year and worst of all
87% that's not a typo 87% of teenagers
in the US have an iPhone and that that
honestly feels like the most damning one
because they that means they got them
early like these are the everyone knows
about the walls Apple builds up around
their ecosystem to try to keep people in
the iPhone Walled Garden but 87% of
teenagers that just means that there's a
lot of these people's first phones these
people will be iPhone customers for life
maybe like for a lot of them their
friends all have iPhones and if they're
going to get their first phone for the
first time they don't really even
consider anything that isn't also an
iPhone it's the only way to get into all
the group chats with their friends it's
the only way to get in on all the inside
jokes and socializations that happen
after school from the facetimes to the
iMessages and all the things that are
just iPhone only so it's a very baked in
thing it's it's a very us Centric thing
for sure but it is everywhere so this is
why when I made that blue bubbles versus
green bubbles explain video I had to put
that disclaimer in the beginning of the
video but that's why half the comments
were like yeah I live in the US and I
see this everywhere there's iPhones
everywhere and the pressure of the
iPhone is very real and then the other
half of the comments are like this is
the dumbest thing I've ever seen why do
people care so much about which phone
people use just just use WhatsApp it's
super easy and so that's why that
dichotomy exists but you know you get
the idea so you are that smartphone
company you're in this position you're
trying break out in the US what do you
do it's a real question and uh as some
of you may have picked up by the title
and premise of this video it's a real
company too it's nothing this is a
company that's made their first two
phones now they've got some accessories
they're trying to break out and their
options seem to be just give up on the
US and never or maybe try to strike a
carrier deal and get in that way but
doesn't seem like it might work
or just lean all the way in in and
embrace the actual heart of the question
the number one problem the biggest asset
of the other side and that's what
they're doing so what nothing has
decided to do and they're announcing
this today is they have built iMessage
into their Android
phone kind of so they've announced a new
app that is going to come out and be
exclusive to the nothing phone 2 to
start and it's called the nothing chat
app and their goal with this is to
literally offer iMessage also on their
phone uh now how does this work you
might be asking great question glad you
asked so I've got it here this is an app
that's co-developed with a company
called Sunbird who has been doing this
for a little while in a restricted beta
you might have heard of it and there's
also a couple of others floating around
like this and basically what it does is
it lets you sign into it using an Apple
ID so you can just sign up for an Apple
account without any Apple products you
sign up for an Apple ID and then you
sign into the app and and it will give
you as many iMessage features as
possible without actually having an
iPhone so okay a couple of things about
this one this nothing chats app when you
first sign in is pretty intuitive uh you
go through the setup process to create a
nothing account and then connect your
Apple ID so like I said you can make an
Apple ID even if you have no Apple
products and then you sign in and then
everything just seems to work fine it's
more or less looking exactly like a
skinned version of the Sun bird Beta app
and so sure enough when you go to
message an iPhone or join any group chat
that has a bunch of iPhones in it things
that would not work with an Android
phone before it basically starts off by
sending through a virtual contact card
asking to merge your contact info with
your Apple ID email address and then
suddenly it all works and you're a blue
bubble and you're texting people with
iMessage from your Android phone also
high quality media is working so you
might have heard of this issue already
this is actually one of my biggest
annoyances but when you message an
iPhone with an Android phone or vice
versa and you send like a video or a
photo it's like super blurry because
it's been compressed a lot to fit in the
file size limits of MMS but now you
actually get that full resolution photo
and video treatment as if you're just
two iPhones talking to each other which
is actually very convenient uh typing
indicators work when another person has
been typing for a while and they're also
working on the reactions as well it's
not in this beta that I've been testing
but they say they're going to have that
around the end of this year but then
number two they're saying that they're
launching this as an exclusive app for
the nothing phone 2 so just this phone
and I imagine future nothing phones as
well to sort of give people that option
where if they were going to buy a new
phone and they really want to be in the
iMessage group chats and all the
iMessage features and they could only
buy an iPhone they'll at least also have
this phone as an option but then three
this is the big one and I cannot stress
this enough this could Le lead to
enormous security issues signing in with
your Apple ID onto a device that you
don't own is an enormous security issue
and it's a huge risk to anyone using it
same thing is also true about beeper and
the others because the way this one
works and I've confirmed this with
nothing is when you sign in with an
Apple ID it's literally signing in on
some Mac Mini in a server Farm somewhere
and that Mac Mini will then do all of
the routing for you to make this happen
you will never see or actually hold or
use that Mac Mini now no one else is
supposed to be able to use or see that
Mac Mini or your messages on it because
it's all encrypted but you are still
logging in with your own Apple ID on
someone else's computer I don't know how
else put that like that on its face is a
big enough risk that many people will
never even want to try this but hey if
you're nothing well maybe this is just
enough to be able to say hey we're
offering iMessage on an Android phone
like this this is a young and crazy
enough company that they're going to try
stuff like this so maybe people consider
a nothing phone in the US instead of an
iPhone that everyone seems to just
choose by default I actually talked to
nothing about this as I was testing it
before this is all going live and I
actually asked Carl pay straight up what
do you think apple is going to do or say
about this once they find out about it
because as this video goes live Apple's
finding out about this um and his answer
was
was honestly probably nothing but just
because there's a weird timeline we're
living in here in 2023 where Apple kind
of can't really retaliate publicly
because they've already been up against
so much Anti-Trust pressure everyone
already knows apple is using iMessage
and its powers to keep people from
leaving the iPhone but if Apple now like
publicly acknowledges this as a
competitor in the space that they've got
to shut down or something like that it
could sort of shine a light on it in a
way they don't actually want uh so
they'll probably just quietly sweep it
under the rug and maybe just point out
some security risks involved with the
whole thing but then of course the other
side of the coin is if Apple cares so
much about security then wouldn't they
want to support RCS so that the millions
of messages that go back and forth
between Android phones and iPhones every
day won't be unencrypted SMS but that's
a that's another story for another day
but at the end of the day the real
question is will it work will this
strategy of offering some iMessage stuff
on their phone exclusively actually work
for nothing to break out in the US and
the fact is there's a there's a nonzero
number of people who will be willing to
try this to give themselves the iMessage
the blue bubble life while still using a
different phone there's probably
somebody out there who's like I might
buy a nothing phone but also all my
friends have iPhones so I guess I can't
and for them this is real it's great but
uh there's a lot of baggage with that
and uh sort of a weird timeline where
we're living in now that this is
actually a possible thing that could
happen let me know what your thoughts
are in the comment section below if you
think this will work thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
[Applause]
peace